la victoria que parece una derrota el
Primer Ministro Mario draghi obtuvo el
voto de confianza del senado votante
133 votantes por mayoría 67 95 en favor
38 en contra será abstenciones
el senado a prueba
pero decenas de senadores de los tres
partidos de su coalición decidieron no
participar en el voto desacreditando el
proceso y debilitando aún más a su
gobierno el Primer Ministro italiano
había convocado un voto de confianza
para tratar de poner fin a las
divisiones de su Alianza después del
boicot de otra votación la semana pasada
por un partido de su coalición el
movimiento 5 estrellas que escuche
durante Qué pasa lo que pasa es que tal
vez Mario draghi debería renunciar
porque en realidad no tiene la mayoría y
más allá de lo que pueda pensar
este jueves al presidente Sergio
matarella el presidente podría entonces
anunciar elecciones legislativas
anticipadas en septiembre o octubre el
Primer Ministro italiano ya había
presentado su renuncia el 14 de julio
Pero matarela se la había negado Mario
draghi consideraba que su gobierno de
unidad nacional ya no tenía legitimidad
por las diferencias que experimenta